que ce soit à travers champs ou à la
lisière de la forêt de rambouillet vous
serez à plus de deux mètres du sol pour
votre balade des promenades à cheval
d'une heure de trois heures ou d'une
journée proposée ici au centre équestre
cheval nature de la commune du tartre
godrans voilà on amène les gens là comme
ça il monte avec l'aide des plots
puisque ça nous on aime bien par rapport
aux chevaux c'est pour ménager leur dos
en fait un très vite de monter tout le
temps ce du sol protéger le dos puis
après ça ils partent ils partent en on
part on part dans les bois là haut et
gens qui savent bien monter qu'on a un
bon niveau
ils peuvent partir seul sans
l'accompagnateur on leur donne une carte
et puisent des bretons les débutants les
accompagne beaucoup plus sont allés on
va aider à préparer les chevaux les
équipes ont leur passent les casques ans
les équipes bien et on leur explique les
bases on l'aimé à cheval et une va faire
un tour beaucoup plus tranquille parce
que les délits temps ça va être beaucoup
du pae un tout petit peu trop raide et
éventuellement ce qu'on peut faire c'est
leur proposez là dans les bacs marron à
boire ce centre équestre existe depuis
près de 30 ans avec une vingtaine de
chevaux de différentes races pour les
balades
nous on travaille beaucoup avec des
trotteurs de
de deux courses qu'on achète assez jeune
pour pour qu'ils aient pas fait de
course à proprement parler et puis
et puis on leur travail tranquillement
pendant un an ou deux pour le boulot
c'est vachement important
les chevaux y bossent bien le week-end
par exemple important que le soir et
puis ce soit libre et puis qu'ils
puissent marché va faire ce qu'ils ont
envie pseudo liberté
on s'est baladé un petit peu dans la
forêt on a profité un petit peu de la
fraîcheur des sous-bois et voilà on a
était surtout au pas les chevaux avaient
surtout assez chaud et puis un petit peu
trop un peu diallo mais voilà en
profiter en tant qu on a mis entre amis
ça me fait du bien d'être dans la nature
d'être au contact des chevaux de
respirer mais j'adore ça
j'adore les chevaux l'été 2010 9 une
année particulière pour ce centre
équestre les participants de la 52e
édition de l'est qui rendent au pourront
venir à cheval nature on sait proposer
en tant que quelques étapes pour les
cavaliers qui seraient de passage pour
les qui rendent au on a dit qu'on ferait
un ce que ça va être le mercredi soir on
va faire un gros barbecue
l'equirando c'est le rendez-vous
d'équitation de l'été
du 2 au 4 août le haras des bréviaires
sera le centre du tourisme équestre
européen
trois jours de fête d'activité de
randonnée dans le sud yvelines pour près
de mille cavaliers participants c'est se
promener à cheval ou en attelage pour
découvrir non seulement la région ile de
france bien sûr
et puis ensuite principalement le
département des yvelines
c'est le retour de l'est qui rendent au
en ile de france la dernière édition
francilienne a eu lieu à provins en 1993